TMS brain health the sponsors of this
segment are making high quality Mental
Health Care accessible for our community
we spoke with their nurse practitioner
here in Las Vegas to learn more about
ketamine treatment
[Music]
welcome to TMS brain health my name is
Judith Leigh teach I'm the nurse
practitioner here at this location in
Las Vegas in this location we do offer
treatments like TMS and we also offer IV
ketamine therapy TMS is transcranial
magnetic stimulation it's an alternative
treatment for people suffering from
treatment resistant depression anxiety
OCD and PTSD it's non-invasive in that
we there's nothing that goes inside your
head it's just the coil that we place on
top of your cortex and we stimulate
those neurons so they start connecting
inside your brain because we found out
like people who are having depression
their neurons are under acting so we
want to wake those neurons so that we
can create neuroplasticity so they can
all connect and fire together and to
complement the TMS that we offer here we
also have in addition ketamine therapy
and what Calamine does is like that
fertilizer that prepares your brain
before we come in and cement it with TMS
so we offer the IV infusion one and we
also do the intramuscular one here at
the clinic some patients may be
experiencing PTSD and they want to work
through those thoughts you know and that
also patients who are having anxiety
patient going through divorces and also
people who have OCD especially people
who are having suicidal thoughts well
they've attempted suicide and they just
want to work through those negative
thoughts so what ketamine does is help
you like navigate through thoughts and
actually alter them so that you are
viewing it in a different way I've also
had clients who've gone through grades
whether they lost somebody they really
love and they're still gripping and they
just want to deal with their grip a
little bit better so we have given them
ketamine and they have been able to work
through those thoughts those negative
thoughts so some of my my patients have
experienced you know feeling way better
than when they walked in they're brought
in by their family members or a friend
that they have seen their friend not
being able to get up or talking about
harming themselves so it's usually
really humbling and rewarding to see
that alleviating within hours of
receiving the academic treatment so
caramel treatment can last for a few
days to a few weeks and some people have
reported a few months so it really
differs from Patient to Patient so how
we administer ketamine here is we do two
infusions per week and a total of eight
infusions but we've also had patients
who only required one treatment and they
have seen amazing results even from
their treatment the treatment itself is
only um 40 minutes infusion and is given
two times a week and it has to be 48
hours apart if you feel like ketamine is
something that can help you or can help
a neighbor a loved one or even a friend
or someone you know that could be
suffering from depression PTSD OCD
anxiety and this might be just that
route that they're seeking please give
us a call or go to our website and book
a consult and we will tell you you if
you are a candidate for Academy
thank you to TMS brain health for
sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at
833-867-2329 or visit
tmsbrainhealth.com for more information
[Music]